a day that seemed to start well for
emmanuel macron as he met supporters in
northern france ended in disappointment
by sunday evening estimated results
showed the french president's centrist
bloc failing to secure a majority in the
final round of france's parliamentary
elections some of macross top officials
and ministers even lost their seats
situation this situation represents a
risk for our country given the
challenges we have to face both at
national and international levels but
we've got to respect this vote and draw
the consequences
there were celebrations at the
headquarters of a new left-wing alliance
that has emerged as the main opposition
the block that includes the far left
greens communists and socialists has
galvanized voters fed up with the macros
policies
it's a totally unexpected situation one
never seen before the derailment of the
president's party is absolute and we
have achieved our political goal in less
than a month
celebrations also for the far right
marine le pen's party projected to win
10 times more seats than it previously
held it's set to become a significant
parliamentary force
you'll be sure to see your ideas on
immigration security and unemployment
defended in parliament
turnout was low reflecting an electorate
increasingly disillusioned by politics
fewer than half of those eligible caste
ballots among those who did issues
including inflation and climate change
were on their minds
the projected results are a major
setback for president macron he wants to
forge ahead with his agenda that
includes welfare and pension reforms as
well as tax cuts but to do so his
centrist alliance needs to work with
other parties that are unlikely to make
the president's life easy you will have
to negotiate
those missing seats to get a majority
and the only
party that seems available for that is
the traditional right the republican
party which comes forth in in the number
of seats
but enough to produce a majority with mr
macron's party
it's a very big surprise because the
republicans did very badly
in the presidential election only two
months ago and they come out as a king
maker of the political situation in
france
in 2017 macross party won a
parliamentary majority in a landslide
that enabled the president to push
through often controversial reforms at
times in the face of street protests his
second term is already shaping up to be
very different and so is the parliament
more fragmented than ever but perhaps a
more accurate reflection of france's
political landscape
natasha butler al jazeera paris